what do you think is the economic
solution though right so like what can
the Federal Reserve do or the US
government how do we stop this that's
that's what this book is saying the
creature from Jekyll Island the name of
the game is bailout their job isn't you
know inflation in this secure economy
whatever they say it is their job is to
protect the rich so they're going to
bail out you know so they bailed out the
biggest corporations they built up
they're bailing out the shadow banking
system right now you know all this you
know that they're bailing out the
commercial paper market right now the
big crash is in the shadow banking
system and corporate credit and those
CEOs who are parachuting out right now
they ripped everybody else borrowing the
companies my like like for its money
they bought back their shares they
parachute out with stock options and
they pay less taxes they pay capital
gains versus ordinary income you know
that I know that but that we have up we
have a zombie company called a TNT you
know IBM generally electric they used to
be triple-a the triple B now our CEOs
are criminals what they've done to our
companies but they're the best and the
brightest from our school system as it's
those peacetime leaders they ripped us
off and so is the Fed ripping us off and
so is our government rippin off Wall
Street the reason our pensions are broke
is because they stuffed our pensions
full of these toxic assets you know
what's the number-one export of America
toxic assets we ship them all over the
world Australia is going to die because
they bought our CD asses at cielos MPS's
they bought all of my toxic assets all
over the world simultaneous and people
go oh I have a college degree what's a
college you in science one of my
favorite things that you've ever said is
that the great live the Federal Reserve
is that it's not a bank
it's not federal and there's no reserves
it's kind of the triple the trifecta if
you will of just the three things that
people think it is none of those three
are actually true and versus a cartel
like the Midian cartel the cocaine
dealers well they're not much different
they're highly educated people like my
poor dad PhDs poor helpless and
desperate and they'll do anything for
that paycheck and that's what's running
our country our world in all this it's
just tragic and it all starts with
education system what the school
teaching about money so the school
systems part of Grudge gross Universal
cash ice buckminster fuller that's why
there's no financial education and
that's the problem and that's what
records are saying in this book the road
to ruin he talks about don't let a good
crisis go to waste because that's what
the fascists stepped in and a fascist
say oh we have this thing called the
corona virus you must have social
distancing you must wear a mask you know
you can't touch you can't battle but you
can do you know I just love Trump he
gets up there he goes yeah you should
wear a mask but I'm not going to screw
you I just had a Tim Kennedy who's a
Ranger qualified Special Forces sniper
come on the podcast and one of the
things that he talked about was this
whole idea of there's a number of states
now that are saying Robert if you're
from New York
you can't come to Rhode Island and if
you come to Rhode Island we're gonna
pull you over and if a neighbor knows
that you came from New York we're gonna
come to your house and question you and
all this stuff and Tim put it great he
goes you know what they should do if
you're from New York they should take
the New York Yankee sign and they should
stitch it into your shirt actually don't
even use a New York Yankee sign why
don't we just start with a star right
and you very quickly can see where are
we going what is happening here and to
your point when people are suffering and
people are desperate they'll take any
violation of their rights their civil
liberties etc in exchange for that
economic kind of safety net which is
what we're seeing occur right now well
that's what my resident always says you
know those two kinds of people in the
world wimps and pimps a whip stands for
where is my paycheck sir and a pimp is
put it in my pocket sugar
so you know like my my friend says you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna get a huge
check because I have employees they're
gonna give me a huge check are you gonna
take the money I said of course what are
you gonna do with it buy more my buy
more gold silver and good coin I don't
need the money but I'm gonna take it
anyway yes but that's not fair I said
well that's fair to me you mean I can't
change the government but I can change
me I can protect my team I can protect
my employees my employees are our flesh
they have very high-paying jobs I show
them I show my cash status they know we
can pay them well so when the government
offered on all three and fifty billion
whatever they did the other day I took
it I just had my CFO fill out the forms
we're gonna take the money I'm just
gonna reinvest it I haven't been
watching my tweets that's all let's say
take the money buy gold silver and
Bitcoin don't be stupid right now yes so
let's switch the individual right you've
got a a mil millions and millions of
people in the United States and they're
now saying okay
here's where we are I wasn't paying
attention I didn't heed the warnings I'm
now sitting facing what is a minimum of
financial crisis if not a depression I
most likely still have a job but that is
in question moving forward what do I do
and I think that's the number one
question people want to hear from you is
just what do you do if you're an
individual today in order to weather the
storm and also put yourself in a better
position for that financial freedom in
the future given the macro environment
for it well I think I should you know
watch your your last videos with Ron
Paul and who was the woman I guess she
was teasing wrong oh she's fantastic
hello I love smart beautiful women you
know I just love I like pretty stupid
women too that's not like you know smart
women too in other words the best
teachers are on YouTube wake up they're
not in colleges anymore the university
system is corrupt they sold out they're
taking all of the student loan money
ripping off our country ripping off the
kids and all this stuff and they're not
teaching me I think that's useful you
know most of these college kids coming
out I can't hire them in fact it's
almost a detriment to say you have a
college degree around my company do I
mean because what do you know
I have a Bachelor of Science they're
gonna go it's 10 for BS that's like PhD
is poor helpless and desperate I can't
hire these guys you know I'm talking
about talking about they're a bunch of
wimps where's my no I don't think so
I think we're on the wrong team yeah so
when you look out and you say okay these
people gotta get educated so step one
get on YouTube get on these platforms
learn from those who are creating all
this content that's kind of step one
step two then is you've always said for
a while now real estate gold silver etc
but I'll consider kind of traditional
inflation hedge type assets what's your
view on those assets right now so forget
Bitcoin for a second just got the more
traditional real estate gold and silver
well first of all real estate gold let
me go this way it's real estate there's
gold silver and Bitcoin the reason is
you're off the central banking system or
outside the system you know if you say
it's the separation of money and
government and that's why I say gold and
silver are God's money and bitcoin is
open-source people's money I don't know
much beyond that but I'd rather have
that than the dollar I don't have to
mess around with a doll because they're
correct but most important this is your
greatest asset your brain or is your
greatest liability and if you're in
trouble today then the liability is
between your left cheek and your right
ear because you absolutely drank some
kool-aid along the way